la cour suprême du canada ouvre la voie
à des chauffeurs d'hubert qui souhaitent
être reconnus comme des employés à part
entière de la multinationale le plus
haut tribunal du pays confirme une
décision de la cour d'appel de l'ontario
qui avait ouvert la porte à une action
collective pour en parler et grenat
co-éco professeur au département de
gestion des ressources humaines à hec
montréal spécialisé en droit du travail
bonsoir madame clicquot bon score mais
si c'est nier alors la cour suprême ne
se prononce pas sur le fond du dossier
qu'est ce qu'elle vient trancher
aujourd'hui
en fait ce qu'elle vient déterminer
clairement c'est à savoir si la clause
d'arbitrage qui étaient insérés dans les
fameux contrats d'adhésion auquel
adhèrent les chauffeurs d'hubert it et
la plateforme hubert si cette clause
d'arbitrage et valley est ce qu'il
s'agit d'un premier pas pour être
reconnus comme des employés à part
entière en fait elle vient déterminer un
élément assez précis de cette du contrat
entre les chauffeurs et la compagnie oui
effectivement ce qu'elle vient dé
terminer en face on peut dire que c'est
une grande bataille déjà de gagner mais
la bataille qui reste à faire est encore
assez longue
je dirais que hubert a démontré à
maintes reprises à quel point il est
pugnace et régulièrement devant les
tribunaux pour faire valoir son modèle
d'affaires
donc on est loin encore d'aboutir
vraiment à une requalification du statut
de travailleur salarié de ses chauffeurs
ceci dit c'est une excellente nouvelle
puisque désormais la clause en fait
d'arbitrage obligeait ses fameux
shoppers a finalement de faire trancher
tous les différends qui les opposent est
en fait à hubert devant un arbitre qui
se trouve donc à amsterdam aux pays bas
ce qui est chercheur est compliqué pour
des choses alors c'est très compliqué
parce que ce sont des chauffeurs
une erreur qui gagnent entre 400 et 600
dollars par par semaine et aux fonds
déjà juste les frais administratifs qui
sont requis par ce
tribunal d'arbitrage donc ces quatorze
mille 500 $ us qui doivent débourser par
le chauffeur par monsieur et leur suffit
absolument déraisonnable
est ce que ça veut dire que les
chauffeurs vont maintenant pouvoir
intenter un recours collectif contre
hubert effectivement effectivement donc
dans un premier temps il va y avoir une
autorisation et l'action collective a
pour but justement de faire valoir le
respect des normes du travail de
l'ontario qui sont prévus dans la loi
sur les normes d'emploi ontarienne à
l'équivalent au fond de notre loi sur
les normes du travail pour le québec il
ya des lois similaires qui vise
justement à faire respecter des normes
sociales telles que salaire minimum les
congés de vacances c'est ça il pourrait
obtenir quand même des conditions
beaucoup plus intéressante s'ils étaient
considérés comme des employés que des
contractuels assure bien sûr bien sûr
évidemment c'est ça les la protection en
matière d'accidents de travail c'est
également les indemnités en cas de
licenciement évidemment à la suite de la
copie de 19 c'est un débat quand même
important parce que ces travailleurs là
ont vu une partie de leurs revenus
diminuer parfois certains ont contracté
la cobi de 19 cents pour avoir les
protections sociales auxquelles un
salarié aurait pu avoir accès c'est un
débat à savoir si ces chauffeurs sont
des des contractuels ou des employés
qu'on retrouve à plusieurs endroits dans
le monde
est ce que au canada ils ont de bonnes
chances d'obtenir ce qu'ils demandent
je pense ça devrait ça devrais je dire
est que la lan man si la nature en fête
de la question qui est posée ici est
légèrement différent il reste que la
majorité de juges se sont appuyés
vraiment sur la question de l'équité et
de la clause donc en me déjà en exergue
l'inégalité du pouvoir de négociation
entre ces chauffeurs et la
multinationale donc en fait
déjà il ya cette espèce de deux lits en
partie posée par par les juges de la
majorité et puis on a le support aussi
d'autres décisions à travers le monde
notamment en transe très récemment la
cour de cassation s'est prononcée pour
la reconnaissance d'un statut de salarié
pour ces chauffards en considérant qu'
on était loin comme l'invoquait la
plateforme hubert d'une miss simplement
en relation entre les chauffeurs et la
plateforme
hubert est plus que ça il a il exerce
véritablement un contrôle non seulement
par le véhicule de la géolocalisation
mais aussi par d'autres mécanismes de
sanction d'évaluation de la prestation
transports alors donc je dirais qu'il ya
quand même des éléments qui sont
présents et qui ont déjà été tranchée
par d'autres élus nous à travers le
monde
il ya d'autres évidemment débat aussi en
californe way est ce qu'on peut quand
même considérer que cette reconnaissance
éventuelle des chauffeurs comme des
employés d'hubert viendrait changer
complètement le modèle d'affaires de
l'entreprise à ce qu'elle demeurait
viable finalement effectivement mais je
pense que le modèle d'affaires repose
justement sur le transfert des risques
non seulement à ces travailleurs qui
malheureusement sont la part du temps
très vulnérable déjà en partant et aussi
aux contribuables parce que finalement
et c'est ce qu'on observe déjà aux états
unis si chauffeur quant aux malades
lorsqu'ils ont mois lorsqu'il ya moins
d'activités
évidemment ils n'ont aucune protection
sociale alors voilà alors on suivra
évidemment le la suite des procédures et
de ce dossier n'a eu pour professeur à
hec montréal merci beaucoup merci je
suis ni encore